right so you're probably wondering why I
haven't made a video in over a week
it's not because I've been busy it's not
because I've been bored of YouTube it's
not because I've had a mental breakdown
it's not because I've died it's just
because I haven't made a video I just
kind of haven't do I have to have an
excuse there's a video here right now
here's a video but watch this video okay
here's a video roll the video
Johnny it's so Charlie yes so tall he is
so cool okay you might have guessed from
the title that this video is about
children in need now if you're not from
the UK you're probably not going to know
exactly what children in need is so I'm
gonna give you the Wikipedia definition
every year since 1980 the BBC has set
aside one evening of programming on its
flagship television channel BBC one to
show advanced aimed at raising money for
charities working with children in the
UK you probably could've guessed from
the title children in need
charities for children raising money
help children me personally I've never
really done anything to try and raise
money for charity but thanks to this I
finally have a chance let's try and
raise some freaking money children in
need slogan this year is do something
different so what I thought was us
youtubers could try and make something
different if you make videos all you
need to do is make a video which is
entirely different from any video that
you've ever made ever they're creative
you're youtubers you can come up with
something because it's for charity I
want to try and raise as much money as
possible so what we need to do for that
is try and get as much exposure as
possible now I'm not saying to send this
video to all your friends I'm saying if
you really really really really want to
help out all you need to do is make a
video just like this one more especially
this gets the more money we were into a
charity so if any of you guys want to do
that and tell people what I'm trying to
do to try and raise money that would be
absolutely awesome so thank you very
very very very much if you want to do
that obviously you don't have to you can
just make something different or you can
just sponsor us to do it you don't have
to do anything if you don't want to I
mean your money go buy an iPod if you
want so how do you sponsor us that's a
pretty good question video description
www dot
giving calm /youtube gone there donate
money and the money goes straight to
children in need and we can see how much
money we've raised because the money is
going straight to children in need it
doesn't go through me which means you
guys can be safe in the knowledge that
I'm not going to take any of your money
going straight to charity thank you guys
for watching go make something different
and go sponsor us to do as well make
something different or a need charity
let's go thank you Joe